the rioters are starting to hit a little
close to home
a little too close for comfort we've
been seeing cities around the country
go up in flames well over the weekend
not so far from our studio
there was a pro-trump rally just people
driving their cars down
the boulevard and the swat team was
called out because some left-wing
lunatic started firing on the parade
from a window
luckily nobody was injured or killed
because generally speaking the left
they're not very good shots but they did
shoot out a tire in the parade
and very few people want to cover that
well unfortunately
uh in some other places conservatives
weren't so lucky because the aim was a
little bit better
we are in a state right now of open
insurrection
in this country it's not just one city
it's not just one state it's all over
the place
and more importantly it's not just
antifa and it's not just
black lives matter it's it's democrats
it's democrats and it's about an
election and at this point there is no
meaningful difference
between antifa and blm and the
democratic party
we'll get into the real power behind
these riots i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday from joe who says
michael i really enjoy watching your
show while eating my mostly vegan
barbecue beef brisket and ribs for lunch
well thank you no i'm so glad
i as you know i am a
fiery but mostly peaceful podcast host
so uh you know it we we fit in well
during these crazy times i want to get
into this there was
uh mayhem to a degree that i had not
seen in this country over the weekend
uh we'll get to what all of that means
not even just for the election even
moving forward after the election
first though got to thank our friends
over at car shield
never a better time never a better time
folks
uh computer systems in the car right now
are the new normal
right and look i don't even know how to
use simple cars i don't even know how to
fix
cars as they used to be made now you've
got electronically controlled
transmissions you got touch screen
displays you've got
sensors galore sensors everywhere and
you can't fix
any of these new features by yourself
and i certainly cannot
when something breaks it can cost a
fortune and now is not the time for
expensive repairs
that is why i love car shield car shield
has affordable protection plans
that can save you thousands for a
covered repair including computer gps
electronics and more
all those things that usually don't get
covered they also have complementary 24
7 roadside assistance
and a rental car while yours is being
fixed go get it guys
these guys are really great they cover
all the stuff that very often
uh you will find doesn't get covered
they've helped over one
million customers drive with confidence
knowing that you are
covered from america's number one auto
protection company right now
for as low as 99 a month you can protect
yourself from surprises and save
thousands for a covered repair call 800
car
6 000 and mention code knowles
k-n-w-l-e-s or visit car shield
dot-com code nose
[Applause]
so a very sad story over the weekend the
leftists
in portland oregon murdered a trump
supporter
just out and out shot him this was not
in self-defense
this was not some sort of unfortunate
accident that nobody
intended this was cold-blooded
deliberate
murder take a listen to the scene
what's at least fortunate about the
fact that we have this video is one it
hopefully will be easier to catch the
perpetrators
and two it's not it's not so gory you
don't see it up close but it's pretty
clear what happened and the audio is
more telling than the video
because what you can hear there is we've
got a trumper right here
we've got a trumper right here this is
not in self-defense you know it's not
someone shot first someone's taking a
swing
we've got a trumper right here bang bang
now initially antifa
and the rest of the left tried to flip
the situation they tried to claim
that they were the victims and that the
conservative or the trump supporter was
the aggressor
that was not true the the victim here is
aaron danielson
also known as jay bishop who's a uh a
conservative guy
andy noe who's done incredible work
covering all of this pointed out that
antifa
was falsely claiming to be the victims
here and
and but then they they kind of admitted
it they admitted that they were the
perpetrators so what did they do they of
course called
this conservative guy who according to
all evidence
around did not do anything wrong they
said that they killed a fascist
not only that they celebrated his death
the person who died was a patriot person
he was a nasty our community held its
own
and took out the trash i am not going to
shout any tears over our nazi
y'all are not angry you're not paying
attention if you're not angry you're not
with me
everybody needs to realize what's going
[Music]
our community can on us without the
police we can take out the trash on our
own
i am not sad that a fascist died tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
and what makes him a fascist that he
supported trump
that's it basically well he
showed up and in support of trump or in
support of conservatives
and listen to the language they use they
refer to fellow human beings as trash
and they celebrate and they laugh about
killing someone and calling it
taking out the trash they they would do
this
they would celebrate killing any of us
right they call him a fascist there's no
no evidence the guy's a fascist
as george orwell pointed out now 80
years ago
70 or 80 years ago the word fascist has
essentially lost all meaning what
they're saying is he's a conservative
he's a trump supporter he's patriotic he
maybe he wore the maga hat
that's what they're saying that could
have been any one of us
any conservative american in this
country they've been calling us
deplorable and irredeemable for years
they've been calling us bitter clingers
for years
listening to that woman listening to
these antifa slash blm people is pretty
chilling because of how honest they are
they say yeah we want you all dead we
want to kill you we hate you
we hate you we think you're garbage we
want to throw you in the trash
and kill you but they have been egged on
to do this for years by people
who are much more presentable than they
are
it's a very short leap from deplorable
and irredeemable
to human trash the mayor of portland ted
wheeler
certainly should be prosecuted for what
he is allowed to happen there
the president has offered federal
support because obviously there's
anarchy reigning on the streets
and the mayor of portland mocked him and
said no i'm not i absolutely don't want
that
and now people are being killed
needlessly they've lost control
all democrats all elected democrats
who have been silent on this issue or
who have
encouraged this and there are many they
bear responsibility here
so so that what do the left-wing media
say about this
how do they make sense of this that you
now have leftist
thugs in the streets just arbitrarily
gunning down without any provocation
guiding down conservatives
well they say no it's actually the
people committing the violence are
actually white supremacists
they're actually white supremacists joy
reid
tweets out the riots are not black lives
matter march has gone wrong
armed white nationalists are mobbing
these cities to take advantage of
protests and scare fellow white people
into quietly siding with them
it's an old tired and true strategy
using fear and anti-blackness for
politics
this is obviously not true right unless
all of these white supremacists are
dressing up
either like ralph northam when he was in
medical school
or like these kind of blue-haired pasty
antifa guys with left-wing insignia
everywhere
these would be the best disguised white
supremacists you've ever seen there
aren't any you look around how many
white supremacists are there in the
country like three
and you look around the people in the
streets are not white supremacists the
people
celebrating these deaths of
conservatives are not white supremacists
so how do they get into this
how do you look at these shootings
how do you look at these shootings and
say actually the
people marching in the name of black
lives matter antiva actually they're
white supremacists
the reason the left has to do this and i
don't think a lot of people have picked
up on this yet
is because they have to justify a
contradiction what the left has been
saying what the media have been saying
now for months
is these protests are not violent you
had a number of journalists yesterday
even
showing nice videos and photos from
really rich areas of washington dc
or or other places around the country
and saying look everything's fine here
there's no violence
say right it's fine in your nice rich
neighborhood what about the other
neighborhoods where i can see the video
i can see the mayhem i can see the fire
you've seen these these journalists on
cnn and
msnbc they'll stand in front of burning
buildings and they'll say oh it's fiery
but mostly peaceful
it's mostly non-violent and of course
that's a lie so they have to deal with
the fact that they've been saying now
for months
it's totally peaceful but also
all this violence is being caused by
white supremacists wait a second i was
told there wasn't any violence
i was told it's totally peaceful yes no
it's completely
100 peaceful also all of the violence
that you can obviously see it's being
caused by
skinheads not very convincing and by the
way
if you want to if you want to figure out
who's celebrating this who's egging this
on who's encouraging this who's
perpetrating this
let's turn not to white supremacist
plaza in washington dc
let's turn to the area that the mayor
named
black lives matter plaza and take a
listen to what they're saying
i'm at the point where i'm ready to put
these police in the grave
i'm at the point where i want to burn
the
white house down
i want to take it to the senators i want
to take it to the congress
i want to take the fight to them and at
the end of the day
if they ain't gonna hear us we burn them
i'm one that talk real i'm talking in
new york
and i'm talking in dc
the same way i police up in new york i
pops up here in dc
the same way i bust police in the head
in new york i'll bust police in the head
of dc
ah those white supremacists i can't
believe
they're allowed to spout their violent
white supremacist red it doesn't sound
doesn't sound like a white supremacist
to me in black lives matter plaza
talking about the exact same riots that
have been going on for months now
that have been egged on not just by the
people on the streets but by the people
at the very top of the media and people
at the very top
of the democratic party we will get to a
congressman accosted not by white
supremacists but by the radical left in
one second
first however we got to thank our
friends over first leaf you know
how much i love first leaf i actually
just got an order put through yesterday
i got
i you know i do it sometimes i do it on
a monthly basis sometimes two or three
months
but you know depending on my travel
schedule and i thought where is my first
leaf i've run out
i had no venophobia you know how afraid
i am of that but finally my my wine is
shipping
i'm clearly i've got to move up the the
shipment calendar here
because i i i did get very nervous when
my first leaf
was dwindling at the bottom of the box
these guys are terrific it's very simple
to
get started you take a quick quiz to
assess your wine drinking preferences
then first leaf sends you six expertly
picked bottles of wine
based on your answers and they're gonna
check things out right so you're gonna
say these are my
flavors that i really like to say okay
that's fine but maybe try to
try this and then you rate it up or down
the more you rate it
the closer it gets so i'll get i'll say
oh this wine there's no way
i don't like this kind of wine there's
no way i'm going to like that i'll pour
it out it's delicious
because they know my taste profiles now
it gets better and better today sign up
get six bottles of wine for only 29.95
plus free shipping go to trifersleaf.com
knowlesk
wlas that is six bottles of wine for
only 29.95
at tryfirstleaf.com i was very skeptical
of wine clubs i always
am and now i've spent i've spent a ton
of money on on firstly because i've had
it for so long and i love it
every time you use it you're saving
money because you get these great wines
at a great price so try first leaf dot
com
slash knowles
a republican congressman brian mast of
florida
who is a war hero lost both legs while
serving
in afghanistan he was walking back from
the rnc from president trump's
acceptance the other night
when roving gangs of was it white
supremacist says joy reid says
no roving gangs of antifa and blm and
other left-wing agitators
mobbed around him mobbed around a
disabled combat veteran
and republican congressman and
intimidated him and started screaming in
his face now of course
this is a guy who's dealt with the
taliban so i don't think he's going to
be worried about these
little left-wing agitators but they have
become violent they have killed people
even this past weekend and so when they
start threatening him that when they
start asking if he's afraid he asks
if he has a reason to be afraid for your
safety
no should i be
what do you think about police killing
black people in this country don't worry
we're going to vote
what do you think about police killing
black people in this country
i don't think anybody should get killed
wrongfully what do you think about
police killing black people how do you
feel about abolition
anybody's right to due process
do you feel about police murdering black
people
anybody murdered is wrong anybody how do
you
black people say the christmas people
[Applause]
we are now in the midst of some cultish
mania
as they just repeated the police
murdering black people police murdering
black people
that isn't happening that isn't
happening you can count
the number of unarmed black men who are
who are killed by the police every year
what what is it 15 14 15 something like
that out of how many police civilian
interactions
by the way unarmed doesn't mean an
unjustified shooting or killing
that what murder are we talking about it
is an imaginary problem it's a
completely fictional problem
but people have been whipped up into a
frenzy in particular
the shrillest person in that video of
course this presumably unmarried white
woman
this white millennial woman who was just
so screechy and shrill and
screaming in this man's face about this
national epidemic that simply doesn't
exist how have they been whipped up into
this frenzy
what would tell people not only to
believe this nonsense but that it is
acceptable
to approach a u.s congressman and
wounded war veteran
and mob around him and start screaming
in his face in the middle of the night
what would convince people of that
elected democrats
the leadership of the democratic party
this is not a grassroots movement
this is not something that's totally
come out of control and you know
responsible democrats are trying to tamp
it down no they invented this
the democratic party is behind this
maxine waters a number of other
democratic leaders
told these people to do this to mob
around them
to get violent don't forget maxine
waters about two years ago
take a listen
you have members of your cabinet that
have been booed out of restaurants
who have protesters taking up at their
[Applause]
house
[Music]
and if you see anybody from that cabinet
in a restaurant in a department store at
a gasoline station
you get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they're not welcome
anymore anywhere she doesn't sound very
different
than those antifa people talking about
the human trash
she doesn't sound very different from
the rioters on the streets now telling
people to mob around them
go to to republicans homes
no justice no sleep where their children
sleep threatening their wives and
children
this is an elected member of the u.s
congress
she should be booted out of that body
she should be
kicked out of congress she should be
kicked out of polite society
but she isn't she's a member of the
ruling class
not just her it's not even just the
electeds what about in the media chris
cuomo fredo cuomo the brother of
new york governor andrew chroma one of
the worst governors if not the worst
governor in america
chris cuomo's got a cnn show how did he
use that platform did he use it
responsibly because he's the adult in
the room
these are the leaders of of the
democratic establishment to say hey
stop the violence we can have protests
but they've got to be civil
no he said exactly the opposite he said
get violent
now too many see the protests as the
problem
no the problem is what forced your
fellow citizens
to take to the streets persistent and
poisonous
inequities and injustice and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful show me where it says that
where the protests are supposed to be
peaceful oh in the first amendment the
first amendment says that where you have
the right to peaceably assemble but not
to violently assemble okay well thanks
for showing me that guys i know that
that was not
his conclusion he goes out there and
says protests don't have to be peaceful
well if they're not peaceful what are
they they're violent
and if they're violent what does that
mean it means you're shooting people
like happened in portland
it means you're going to people's homes
and threatening their wives and children
this is what cnn is openly calling for
it's even more recent than that joe
biden's campaign staff
joe biden the democratic nominee for
president
13 members of joe biden's campaign staff
made donations
to a bail fund to bail out the rioters
who were burning down the cities
and killing people 13 members
this goes back to minnesota during the
first wave of these riots
after the george floyd killing
although now we've got new details on
the george floyd kill right we were told
it was caused because a cop
asphyxiated him with his knee now it
seems from leaked
documents from the medical examiner it
may have had something to do
with the massive more than lethal dose
of fentanyl in his system
that may have contributed to it of
course that that doesn't come out in the
media either
regardless 13 biden campaign staffers
donated to bailout the people burning
down
the city how about keith ellison former
vice chairman of the democratic national
committee
a current attorney general in in
minnesota
former congressman keith ellison smiling
with a copy of the antifa handbook
a handbook justifying political violence
there he is he's smiling
and then worst of all the
former future president hillary clinton
after she lost
and they were not able to reclaim the
presidency for her in the attempted coup
d'etat
hillary clinton put all of her cards on
the table he
she said you can't be peaceful you can't
be civil
with republicans you cannot be civil
with a political party that wants to
destroy
what you stand for what you care about
that's why i believe
if we are fortunate enough to win back
the house and or the senate
that's when civility can start again but
until then the only thing that the
republicans seem to
recognize and respect is strength
you can't be civil you've got to use
strength so when you're civil when you
have civil society you debate things you
you argue your points you bring it to
the voters the voters decide
but she's saying you can't do that with
republicans why because republicans
oppose the things that i want
so she's this isn't like this is the
actual threat to our self-government
right which is
yeah we can all be peaceful and civil so
long as you give me everything that you
want
and when can we have civil society again
she says well when i'm back in power
and what do we do until then we show
strength we use strength what does she
mean by strength she means force what
does she mean by force what does she
mean by not being civil she means
violence
she means the shooting of people in
portland she means burning down the
cities
she means toppling our buildings and
looting our stores
how many times do we need to see this
and hear this before we get it
keith ellison smiling with the antifa
handbook there is no antifa there is no
blm there is no democratic party it's
all the same thing
all of those groups exist but they're
all part of the exact same phenomenon
and to describe them as though they're
completely separate well antifa is bad
but blm is good and the democrats are
good or blm
yeah they've gone too far they're
communists they're self-described
marxists
but the democratic party is okay the
democratic party
is antifa is
blm it's all the same thing
the democratic politicians are the
mainstream media are
the educational apparatus and their
wills are enforced their strength is
shown
by the terrorist wings known as antifa
and black lives matter
it's all part of the same exact system
they are not opposed to one another they
work perfectly in tandem
they all the people on the streets right
now are just following orders
who's giving the orders you just heard
them you just heard them from cnn
and hillary and maxine waters and
all the others this is a much
much deeper problem than some anarchists
in the streets you know
some people are letting the democrats
off the hook a little bit here they say
oh look
they played a little bit with fire they
got a little too close
and spun out of control and now they
want to stop it they don't want to stop
it because of the violence
they don't want to stop it because now
people are getting killed they called
for this
and they don't like these they hate
these people they call them deplorable
irredeemable bitter clingers
the only reason they now want to calm
down with the riots is as don lemon said
because it's starting to show up in the
polls
because it's going to start hurting
their chances of being elected
they're still telling people to do this
they're still
presenting the ridiculous basis of
all of the premise of all of this
rioting
donald trump is divisive right donald
trump is a racist
no the obamas were far more racist
and far more divisive than donald trump
and for the one obama that's still in
the
in public life michelle obama she's
making that abundantly clear michelle
obama now has a podcast
everybody's got a podcast everybody
these days has a podcast michelle has a
podcast
in which recently she said that white
people do not
acknowledge that non-white people even
exist take a listen i've had it
several times where i've presented to
members of my team
people that i've worked with peers go
downstairs in the elevator
go out to lunch and they walk right by
you on the street you're standing
in line next to them at sweet green and
they look right through you
they assume they don't know you they
have no use for you
and yet you just help solve their legal
problem
or help make them some money or save
them some money
but then when you're out in the world
you're just an invisible
person what is she saying here
specifically she's saying
i people that i would work with didn't
want to socialize with me outside of
work
it must be because they're racist it
must be because they're bigots
you ever think maybe it's you you ever
think maybe you
are a little unlikable you ever think
that you or you this woman who says i've
never loved my country i've never been
proud of my country until it elected my
husband
you who are saying all white people are
racist because they don't see black
people
who speak in these awful divisive tones
you ever think maybe it's you
maybe it's not the color of your skin
it's just that
you're not likable you're not a likable
person because you're contemptuous of
everybody else
no that's not possible right she goes
beyond work she talks about this
experience she had
this great slight she had as first lady
in an ice cream shop that proves
systemic racism when the girls were
little
this is when i was first lady i am
michelle obama the first lady of the
united states
of america of america and we had just
finished the taking the girls to a
soccer game we were stopping to get ice
cream
and there was a line and once again when
i'm
just a black woman i noticed that white
people don't even see me they're not
even
looking at me so i'm standing there with
two
little black girls another black female
adult they're in
soccer uniforms and a white woman cuts
right in front of us to order like she
didn't even see us
now so i stepped up and i said excuse me
i said you don't see us four people
standing right here you just jumped in
line she didn't apologize
she'd never looked me in my eye she
didn't know it was me
does anybody seriously believe that
while michelle obama was the first lady
of the united states
someone didn't recognize her at the ice
cream shop around where she lives
does anybody seriously believe that no
of course not so what does this amount
to what
what is the scene they're in an ice
cream shop
and someone they're waiting somewhere
and then someone
goes ahead in line and then michelle
obama says hey
i'm waiting here and then the woman
backs away
but doesn't you know talk to her or
anything doesn't look at her
has that ever happened to you regardless
of the color of your skin or anything
like that
anyone ever accidentally cut you in line
or maybe you're in a shop and
they're not sure are you waiting for
your order or have you ordered yet and
someone goes ahead of you has that ever
happened
of course it happens all the time i'm
not saying every time you go into a
restaurant or a shop or an ice cream
shop
but a lot of the time have you ever cut
someone accidentally
yeah i have i did it like two weeks ago
and then let's say that that person you
cut
this this woman who makes damn well sure
you know i'm the first lady
of the united states of america of amer
i'm the first lady michelle obama
i'm so important i'm so wonderful listen
to my podcast read my book
all about me my favorite subject you
think maybe you might be a little
intimidated you might
you might not make you might not be the
most gregarious person there maybe you
don't make eye contact
when you're talking to one of the most
powerful people in the world you ever
is that possible no no it can't be
just a personal just a slight not just
actually not a personal side it's a
racial slight
because they're all racist because
they're all out to get you michelle
michelle obama the greatest victim in
the history of the world michelle obama
the rich
famous beloved former first lady of the
united states
after this horrible racist nation
elected her husband president
twice because of how racist it is they
sure fooled them oh man they didn't
realize he's a black guy
because they're so racist they would
never elect a black guy right they would
never give her
zillions of dollars to read her stupid
book or listen to her
stupid podcast oh no wait a minute the
reality is completely the opposite
completely the opposite doesn't matter
though this grievance narrative man that
sure sells books
talk to robin deangelo talk to the white
fragility people or
any of these other race hustlers it
sells a lot this grievance thing sells a
lot of books
and so that's what we focus on rather
than have gratitude
for our country which abraham lincoln
famously tells us in the lyceum address
is the only way that we're going to
preserve our country is to have
gratitude and reverence for our founding
for our institutions
even the greatest beneficiaries of those
institutions and
of that founding and in this country
some of the most powerful privileged
people
in the entire country they tear it down
you know it just it sells better sounds
but feels so good
to do that this is not about seeing
people this is not about saying
anybody's name
because some of the most prominent
politicians in this country who have
seen lots of people who have said names
still get mobbed still get threatened
with violence we'll get into that we'll
also get into the sad story
of bella thorne someone i had never
heard of until i found out that a movie
star
decided to make a quick buck turning
into a porn actress we'll get into that
first though i want to thank you
for subscribing to the michael knoll
show youtube channel we are now
closing in on 200 000 subscribers we
appreciate it uh you can check out my
latest attempt to guess
a woke tv commercial i've been trying
this now the tv commercials have gotten
so woke you can never tell what the
product is
i felt i got a little bit better on this
one but you can check it out for
yourself on the youtube channel
this week's commercial was requested by
one of our viewers maybe the most
absurd one yet good luck trying to guess
it go to dailywire.com
knowles by the way and subscribe we will
be right back with a lot more
michelle obama's disgusting racist
slander that white people don't see
black people that they don't know that
they
exist this plays into a
story that a line that we've heard
throughout this whole
protest season which is say her name
it's referring to the shooting of
brianna taylor
which the left is trying to pretend that
this woman was completely innocent and
had nothing to do
with major drug deals or that
the people inside of the apartment
didn't shoot first or any of these sorts
of things
however let's take all of that for
granted let's say that there was an
unjust shooting in the case of brianna
taylor we can get into that case maybe a
little bit later in the week
into the specifics because it's being
completely misreported but let's
let's just take them at their word that
this was an unjust killing
there is a u.s senator who sponsored
a bill naming rihanna taylor to stop
no knock search warrants by the police
do you think that the the mobs the
left left wing blm antifa those people
the foot soldiers of the democratic
party
you think they said oh there's rand paul
he said her name okay he's a good guy
we're not going to mob him and threaten
his life
now
okay
[Music]
oh
you can see i love here that rand paul
when when this
mob starts pushing on this cop almost
knocks the cop down
the cop who's protecting him i love that
rand paul then turns back and like grabs
the cop
like you're alright cop because rand
paul has had a
large share of violence in the last few
years that bernie bro almost mowed him
down
during the congressional baseball game
shooting then his insane leftist
neighbor
broke his ribs and nearly killed him in
a personal attack and now he's got this
mob he's probably looking at the mob
like yeah go ahead make my day
come on you're feeling lucky punk so he
he
leans down and helps the cop but there's
this irony because all they keep sharing
say her name say her name
rand paul has said her name more than
anybody in the case of brianna taylor
doesn't matter it has nothing to do with
an actual demand they're not saying say
her name okay here's her name okay we're
good
no it has everything to do with
mob violence to permanently
shut out silence shut up even to the
point of
violence and death republicans and
conservatives
you know the deplorables the
irredeemables the fascists
the the trash that's what it's about
there's there's nothing you can say that
will pacify this mob
they want you silenced forever
there are now roadblocks in dc like
we're some third world country like
we're some tin pot dictatorship
right now you're trying to come in and
out of dc in certain areas you will be
stopped by a mob
that will check your car that will force
you to say things
and tell you just to get out of your car
because that's what you want to do when
there's a violent mob nearby get out of
your car right that's worked out so well
for so many of the other victims of the
blm slash antifa slash democratic party
riots
[Music]
right
so you see this guy's walking up to the
car he's kind of joking into the camera
he's getting in this driver's face
this driver is just a sort of like sad
looking white guy
[Music]
he's trying to listen to her she says
listen to black women she's hey
this guy looks like this guy's on the
verge of tears please snow guys come on
please no
why why he says it he says he's about to
cry
look at him
i also love this shrieking hyena in the
background
listen to black women you're not making
a good argument
for your for your request i don't i
don't
does everyone sound like you because i
don't if if that's the case
it's like that shrill white woman who's
shrieking in that guy's face
let's talk about cops killing black
people he was like uh huh
lady come calm down i think there's i
don't think the
primary problem here is necessarily
racial so much as
uh there's this cultural issue with
these young
shrieking women who are not making us uh
particularly amenable to listening but
the guy is listening the guy leans in he
says
what are you trying to say she doesn't
care she doesn't want to be heard she
just wants to scream
and then you see this guy coming up to
him intimidating him saying come on get
out of the car
get out of the car this is the kind of
thing you would expect
driving through a third world country
but it's not it's happening in america
not just some places in america
multiple cities not just multiple cities
our nation's capital
how long before we're officially a
failed state
how long like at what point did
venezuela get declared a failed state
at what point did zimbabwe get declared
a failed state at what point did syria
where libya because this kind of
behavior
if you told an american that this would
be happening in our country 10 years ago
they would not have believed you
and over what requests that have been
met
right say say her name to rand paul who
wrote a bill
naming her and over
premises that are false that there's an
epidemic of cops killing black men in
this country
innocent you know unarmed black men
and really what it's over is
elected democrats and democrats in the
media
calling for the violence how long
how long before were a failed state this
is the issue
that was at the heart of the civil war
okay
there are a lot of issues in the civil
war i mean especially slavery there was
also this question of states rights
but the the issue that everyone agrees
on
is this question of self-governance
why did the south secede why did the
south not
revolt right we just had an american
revolution the century prior why not
have
a southern confederate revolution why
was it called secession
because to have a revolution requires
that you acknowledge
a natural right natural law right we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and
that's where we drive our power to
revolt against an unjust government
but the south was founded explicitly on
racial supremacy
it was founded on slavery so they
couldn't revolt it would have been an
incoherent revolution
they had to secede but you can't secede
because when you secede
you totally undermine self-governance
the the the agreement that we come to
with self-governance is
we're gonna come together we're gonna
have a country and sometimes you're
gonna win sometimes i'm gonna win
but we're gonna stay together as a
country regardless and we're not just
going to take our ball and go home when
we lose
because if you do that of course that
that's no self governance at all that's
just
that's extortion right that's that's
that's not
a republic what do we have now
we have hillary clinton herself saying
when you lose
you or when we lose not when you lose
when you lose we're happy when we lose
we're going to get violent we're going
to threaten your lives and the only way
we're going to stop
is when you lose and you let us take
over again
joe biden said he made the same threat
he said we can't take four more years of
this
people thought this was some sort of
pious sentimental lament
no it was a threat you can't take four
more years but you're gonna get four
more years if you're reelectrum so just
like to me it'll be easier
it'll be look that's a nice business you
got there should be a shame if something
happened to it
it's a nice that's a nice life you got
there sure would be a shame if something
happened to it
people always ask are we in the run-up
to a civil war i hope not
but there are parallels between right
now in the 1850s
and the same party that pushed us to the
civil war in the 1850s
seems to be hell-bent on pushing us
toward it now
it's an issue of self-government and
actually you know self-government works
on the political level but it also works
on the personal level
you have to govern yourself you have to
discipline yourself if you want to have
a self-governing republic all of our
founders knew this
so what about on that personal level
what about on that cultural level
we have the sad story of bella thorne
i don't know who bella thorne is i've
never seen bella thorne in any sort of
tv show or movie but am told she's a
very famous tv
and movie actress now she's also a
pornographer
how'd that happen here's the quick
rundown of the story it shows you
just about everything that's wrong from
the personal to the to the public
political
level in our culture bella thorne
sent nude photos to her boyfriend
electronically
those photos got hacked which always
happens
when you're always liable for that to
happen and if you're famous it certainly
will happen
when you are when you are in the public
right so she
gets hacked this guy was extorting her
said he was going to leak the photos
so she started an onlyfans.com account
onlyfans.com is this website
that allows anybody to become their own
pornographer and make money selling nude
photos and videos and otherwise
degrading themselves
so she started in onlyfans.com to leak
the photo herself
she made one million dollars in one day
and she made two million dollars in one
week
she was already a millionaire but she's
making a lot of this money
now she's supposedly a victim here
because someone hacked her photos
but whoopi goldberg a left winger on the
view had the audacity to say you know
if you're famous you should use a little
bit of prudence
if you're famous you probably shouldn't
send nude photos because
those photos inevitably are going to
leak
if you're famous i don't care how old
you are
you don't take nude pictures of yourself
you only want to share with one person
but she said
listen when they're hacking you they're
hacking
all of your stuff so whether it's one
picture or a million pictures
once you take that picture it goes into
the cloud
and it's available to any hacker who
wants it and if you don't know that in
2019 that this is an
issue you you i'm sorry your age does
not
you don't get to do that i got to tell
you i kind of like whoopi goldberg even
though i know she's a left winger and
sometimes she has these
fits of of politics on on the view
but she does have a kind of basic
conservatism she realizes
you know you think you take that photo
and it's private it's not private
when you take a digital photo it's never
private when you go on onlyfans.com
that's not ever private
anything on the internet is public the
only question is
who's looking at it and how many people
have seen it so far so if you're famous
and you don't want these new photos to
get out there
just don't take them pretty simple right
we used to say this to people like hey
don't create pornography of yourself
that used to be
not just an acceptable point of view
that used to be very good advice
bella thorne was furious she said shame
on you i don't want to go on the view
anymore because i don't really want to
be beaten down
by a bunch of older women for my body
and my sexuality
blaming girls for taking photos in the
first place is sick and honestly
disgusting no it's good advice
it's good advice let me reiterate
whoopi's brilliant advice
ladies do not take nude photos of
yourself do not take them
do not send them to that boyfriend that
you really like where you're sure you're
going to be together forever and
he would never do anything wrong with
them do not upload them to the cloud
even though they're going to get
uploaded to the cloud the minute you
take them just don't do it
why would you do it what's the point of
doing that you will only regret it
i got i got a message from someone who
had an only fan's account this was a
message that was sent in
through the website not through that
website through my website and
she had this problem pertaining to her
only fans account was trying to
work her way through it and i i said
okay i'm happy to try to help you sort
out this
tangential problem but here's the first
problem you're on only fans get off of
only fans don't do it
there is no good that can come of that
there is only harm that can come of that
you will regret every moment that you're
on there the money isn't worth it
the money isn't it's not even that much
money i guess for for bella thorna
david's two million dollars that
actually
gets to be part of the problem but it's
not just
don't do it i guess you're not allowed
to say that these days
because that's it's somehow feminist to
get women
to to sell their bodies
and it's misogynistic to tell women
not to be degraded and objectified
that's the
wait a second i'm seeing some i'm seeing
a little illogic in that
in that framing but actually this this
money is a little bit of the issue
because that's not the end of the story
here
thorin puts these nude photos up the
customers apparently felt that
thorne was not sufficiently nude in the
photos and they had paid 200
for the photos pretty expensive photo so
they demanded a refund and i want to
take a pause here
everything is public on the internet
everything okay
why on earth if you really wanted to see
a nude photo of bella thorne
wouldn't you just like wait for some
other guy to pay 200
and then for that photo to inevitably
leak we know the photo's gonna leak the
original photo leaked and that was on
her private
cloud account you know it's going to get
out there why would you pay the 200
these people not not thinking with their
upper
upper regions so they got upset they
wanted a refund but now you're talking
about two million dollars going back and
forth on this website so only fans said
okay this is too big a problem
we're in a cap how much you can charge
at 50
okay fine enough but now the other
pornographers are upset
the other women or sometimes the men who
are prostituting these women are very
upset
that the cap is going to be 50 bucks we
were making more money so what happened
bellathorn apologized
bellathorn said i wanted to bring
attention to the site the more people on
the site the more likely the chance to
normalize the stigmas
and in trying to do this i hurt you i've
risked my career a few times to remove
the stigma behind sex work porn and the
natural hatred
people spew behind anything sex related
hatred they spewing hate i don't know
that it's hatred
certainly exploitation and degradation
but i don't know if it's hatred i wrote
and directed a porn against the high
brows of my peers and managers
because i wanted to help with the stigma
behind sex
i am a mainstream face and when you have
a voice a platform and you try to use it
and helping others and advocate for
something bigger than yourself
again in this process i hurt you and for
that i'm truly sorry
i'm sorry women i'm sorry that i in any
way discouraged you from degrading
objectifying and selling yourselves
please go back and objectify yourself
sell yourself please
everybody involved in this entire
situation
is doing the wrong thing except for
whoopi goldberg
whoopi goldberg is the one person who
gets it and she didn't even go that far
she didn't say all girls should not take
nude photos of themselves
she said girls who are famous who know
they're going to get hacked eventually
shouldn't take nude photos of themselves
how how do we get
from that culture to a good
self-governing
society that that recognizes virtue and
can have logical conversations
you can't that's the problem that's the
problem i'm not
i'm using this only fans bella thorne
thing
as one example obviously there are many
issues beyond
sex sex is the most scintillating of
them probably
but this gets into fraud this gets into
other personal relations
this gets into how we do business in the
country this gets into how we look at
our local communities
this looks into the relationship we have
to labor this looks into the
relationship we have to slave labor
overseas
if you don't have a robust moral sense
and you don't actually practice virtues
and you don't even understand the
argument for practicing the virtues
as many people here other than
apparently whoopi goldberg does
you can't have a self-governing country
your country is only as good as the
people
your ability to regulate your country is
only as good as the
people's ability to regulate themselves
so what do we do some some conservatives
throw up their hands they say well
there's no way to legislate morality
that's obviously bs
all laws legislate morality all laws
make moral arguments
right down to parking meters you can't
have the whole
the way you legislate is by making moral
arguments for the laws
and then enforcing those laws so of
course you can now you don't want to
have a tyrannical
regime that is uh that is undermining
public morality which can happen as well
i think we're pretty far from that at
this point though
why don't we take back our politics in a
way that can go in and say hmm
shouldn't be doing that shouldn't be
doing this we
forget onlyfans.com which certainly
should be heavily regulated probably
into the dust
probably just outright banned because
also what are the what are the safety
guards here how do we know that people
under 18 aren't on this website
of course they're on this website so
there are many legal ways to go after a
website like that
but we have such a loss of respect for
law
law and order in this country that we
can't even tell murderous
rioters on the streets to put the guns
down
ted wheeler won't do it he's fanning the
flames
democratic party fanning the flames of
this encouraging him
saying please go out there mob them get
violent
that's not just a personal problem
that's not just a cultural problem it
all ties into this bigger problem
we're trying to we're looking at it in
these little pieces we're just seeing
the trees here you got to zoom out and
see the forest
the personal problem as the left says
the personal problem is the political
problem
and the political problem ties in not
just blm not just antifa
it's the democratic party it's the whole
edifice in the face of that
where do you stand in november what do
you see the stakes as in november
getting more intense and more intense
and more intense
and we always hear this most important
election in our lifetimes
when your opponent tells you that when
they tell you what they're going to do
to you if they get back in power what
they tell you what they're going to do
if they don't get back in power believe
them
that's our show i'm michael gnosis
michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen